daily dose of drama from the folks over
at Vanderpump Rules I mean we're just
trying to keep up with this I can't keep
up new day new Scandal controversy this
one that could pay off big time for
Bravo
ratings wise are you guys thinking it
will be the biggest reunion in Bravo
history the entrance level is high I
think it's going to be pretty big new
Ariana Maddox video Sandoval's ex
Fanning the Flames rocking yet another
red Revenge dress
as last night's episode dropped more
Easter eggs about Sandoval's secret
affair with Raquel Levis playing out
behind Ariana's back but practically in
front of her face are you saying we're
calling it feels like she's living in
some sort of rom-com
and I think she's the only one in it I
think that your self-worth comes from
approval of a man it was my mother who
said be careful with this when she moves
like a snake can we discuss Sandoval
grabbing Raquel's butt right next to
Ariana did you clock that I did clock
that but it's just so you never suspect
it because you're like he wouldn't do
that in front of all of us would he if
they were sleeping together almost two
months after that moment with the affair
well underway we asked Sandoval and
Ariana about breakup rumors every week
There's a new rumor we're like the
Angelina Jolie and Brad Pitt like in
that sense of like remember when they
like first got together it was literally
like a week after they got together
break break up break up we've been
together for almost nine years at this
point so we have not broken up but I
totally understand because I like to
gossip about people that I watch on TV
too
Yeah by all accounts Ariana was a super
trusting friend to Raquel while all this
was unfolding which leads us to what is
turning out to be the next big Raquel
twist another Ariana betrayal you're
going to die there's one conversation in
the in the finale episode oh boy and
she's sick yes it's very upsetting yeah
I asked Raquel about it about how she
could look in her eyes and have that
conversation when you see this stuff
happen is it like ratings goal for you
well I mean you know it's interesting
content but there's you know real people
involved
foreign